rocky theas is there with more on their
exhibits on sites with deep roots in
both las vegas
and black history rocky
thank you so much christian before we
get to the black history month i want to
talk to don
vice president of the neon museum we
were standing here and trying to figure
out where to stand
so you guys do have social distancing
absolutely now they can come visit
safely
well we wipe down everything we take
your temperature when you arrive
and we have these lovely little stickers
that tell you exactly how far apart you
are so
you can move away if you feel like
you're too close to someone and
obviously we are in the great outdoors
so it's very safe you guys come get down
here get some fresh air and get a
history lesson
that's right get a history lesson let's
talk black history we're here at our
next
next sign this one is kind of hard to
see but it says silver slipper
and this was a site in 1950 of an event
hosted by the n double
n double acp for black history month
what makes this significant is at that
time
you could not rent a room downtown or on
the strip to host a black event so
this was one of the first and these
these stories are not getting i mean
this i'm really enjoying this guys if
you're not noticing so let's move on now
to last but certainly not least this is
really special this is actually in
the neon museum's logo so yes this is
our logo but it's also the la concha
paul revere williams designed this this
facility
um it's the 60th anniversary of the la
concha this year and february is prw's
birthday so
a better reason to come but you'll see
it shaped like a shell
when you come to the museum to pay us a
visit you're going to enter a building
that looks just like this on the outside
and so we want you to come down you can
go to www.neonmuseum.org to buy tickets
you can come on a guided tour you can
come and just walk around by yourself
or you can get a combo and see a guided
tour and our other experience called
brilliant
and what we were thinking what we were
talking about earlier before the shot
here
is that this is the perfect time to come
down because you kind of get that
golden hour plus night time right this
is amazing because
you can see the outline of the signs as
well as the lights that are on them
and it's beautiful at night as well but
you see mostly the lights you don't see
the outline of the signs but
anytime's a good time to come down is a
good time to come down anytime is a
great time to celebrate black history as
well so come on down to the neon museum
thank you so much dan this was really
special come back again
i will thank you i'll connect you guys